so the yield photo drummer project
about three years ago when Lauren Tilton
who is a graduate student in the
American Studies department was working
on a project where she was using
photographs from the FSA owi collection
which is a collection of 165,000
photographs that were taken by the US
government between nineteen thirty-five
and 1945 and because they were taken by
the federal government they're amazingly
open source and because they're housed
at the Library of Congress which is
awesome they digitize them all and so
you can go online and see all 165,000
images and all of the metadata that's
also attached to them so which what's
really great is that since these were
all made at the same time by the same
group there are a lot of pieces of
metadata that like basically when you're
when you're trying to apply something
such as Dublin core to all the paintings
in the Louvre or something there they're
naturally going to be pieces of metadata
that are specific to certain paintings
and not specific to others what's great
about this collection is there are
things such as something called a lot
number which is the assignment that a
photographer was on there's a certain
classification hierarchical
classification system which I'll show
you a visualization of so what's really
great about this collection is that it
has fantastic metadata it's all
digitized and it's all open source
wasn't fantastic about it at least when
Lauren was working on it is that the
only way to explore the collection is to
go on to the Library of Congress website
and just search for things there's like
Google you know Google style search for
something and you can type in cows and
you'll see pictures of cows pictures of
cheese if you want to see them if you
know a photographer or a place you can
take those all in and that's really
great if your research concerns one
specific location or one specific type
of photo or sometimes like Migrant
Mother if you're familiar with that one
is in this collection sometimes people
are interested in one specific photo and
that's great but Lauren studies more
like representation of like race and
ethnicity and she was interested in how
the collection as a whole was actually
characterizing race in the United States
during the Great Depression and World
War two and for her it wasn't enough to
look at the individual
photos she was actually interested in
the whole collection and and what was
the collection as sort of looking at
patterns and things what the collection
was showing her and so as a statistician
she was showing me this and I'm thinking
open data and I can download it and
there's there's a lot of it and I was
just like giddy and so the project sort
of came from that and we downloaded it
and started playing around with it and
making visualizations and as we did that
it was just there were more deep
questions and more exciting things that
we learned about it and so from that
point we actually started developing a
team and I think that's the theme have
been hearing at this whole this whole
day is that you know digital humanities
it's all about the team and so we got
the buy-in from Laura Wexler who's a
professor of American Studies and is
Lauren is adviser to direct the project
we had Stacie maples who's in the map
collection here Kim panko who was that
who was formerly at Yale instructional
technology I'm and then Peter Leonard
when he when he came here has also
joined our team and then scrolling down
we also got we went we actually went to
the physical library of congress and
talked to the people who are curating
them and asked them you know like if you
could visualize this how would you do it
and what are things that we don't know
there are a lot of the metadata wasn't
very well documented but it was there
which is great and we were able to work
with them and do things that they
couldn't do because they have a lot of
restrictions because of like 88
compliance and time resources and so
they were really happy to work with us
and we won a National Endowment for the
Humanities grant and so all of this came
together and now we're actually at the
point this fall where we have a working
website it's at photo grammar dot yelled
edu it's sort of in a still testing
phase but we're kind of a soft open so
before it was behind a firewall and now
you can share it and look at it and
we're trying to get advice from people
about you know how could you add what do
we have to explain a little bit better
load testing and all of these things
before making sort of an official
announcement and putting it out to the
public at large so I thought I would
just spend a little bit of time showing
you a demo sort of the way that that we
visualize people going
through the the website so probably the
most exciting thing is the map so this
is a chloroplast map of all the counties
in the US where photographs from this
collection were taken so you can see
some of them are shaded very heavily and
that's where there are a lot of photos
and some of them are shaded more lightly
that's where there weren't quite as many
sure so one thing you can do is that
like I said the screens cutting me off a
little bit but I can limit the years and
only look at say the first year of the
collection and I can see that it was
much more concentrated in the rural
areas less so than the cities and for
instance when I go and look at the later
years when they were losing funding we
see they were mostly in the neighborhood
of DC which was cheaper and easier to
photograph and so putting the whole nap
back what we've observed when we were
doing using user testing is that
everybody's first thing they do is they
try to find their hometown which makes a
lot of sense and it's one of the
exciting things about this collection is
that it spans most of the u.s. so my
hometown is in Brunswick Maine justing
in Cumberland County so I can click on
that and I see that there are 43 photos
so clicking in I can actually see all of
the photos here zoom out oh there we go
and so you can see that these are all
the photographs that were taken and
digitizing the collection and they range
from things such as like the wharf in
Portland which is now all restaurants
flooded homes in sebago lake and then my
favorite is the Hermit of Maine which is
this pipe smoking organist who lives all
alone somewhere in Maine and so you can
start to people start to connect with
this collection and I think that's why
it's been so popular is because
everybody came from somewhere and if
you're from the US and you're not from
one of these random spots where they
didn't take photographs there are going
to be photos that you know and places
that you've seen you know 70 80 years
are going and it's just really exciting
to see that so as everything there's a
lot of metadata attached to this
collection that that is special to this
collection so one of them that's kind of
the most exciting is on these
classification tags which
hierarchical classification of subject
classification of the photographs in the
collection so for instance this is
categorized people as such groups and
individuals middle-aged men and so if we
wanted to see other middle-aged men we
could click on this and see all of them
are we were one there's also an old man
and really old man and we were wondering
who decided where the cut-offs were
there and how political that got but and
so you can see all the photographs that
are that are stored like this and from a
metadata MLS side thing this is really
interesting because these are the
categories that they're the physical
prints are stored out in the library of
congress so now in nowadays in computing
we can do like Peter does you know add a
bunch of keywords in search and we can
we can have a photograph exist in seven
different categories or a hundred
different categories but at the time
this one photograph had to go in one
drawer and so this was the
categorization they actually used for it
and so if instead of so one way to drill
into the collection is to start at the
map and then go to a specific
photographing and see similar ones but
another way of doing it is to look at
the whole set of classification tags and
drill down so for instance these are the
the top-level category so we could click
on transportation and then let's say we
wanted tourists because I'm not really
sure how that's transportation and then
so I guess there's only one sub category
in there and then we'll see the 18
photos that are in that folder and if
you go to the library of congress it's
actually pretty exciting you can go and
open the right drawer and the right
binder and pull them out and you'll see
presumably as long as they haven't
gotten miss or miss organize these 18
photos that are in there um so it's
pretty interesting when you go there and
put the collection back together with
the website but this lets you do it from
anywhere instead of having to go
physically to DC to do it and so the
last thing I'll show you which is which
is actually added a lot more context to
this than I think we even realized that
it would is so these are chloroplasts
and what we this record with Matt where
we've shaded each county by how many
photos there are but another way to do
it is simply to put it dot where every
photograph where every photograph was
taken and it's a pretty big jumble but
I can get it in here so but what it
really becomes interesting is I can put
the 1937 Seaver map on top of it so this
is the map I'm told I wasn't alive in
1937 but I'm told that if you were
driving around and you didn't have a GPS
on your phone you would use one of these
maps and that's how you would figure out
where you were going and so what's
really fascinating is if we zoom in to a
specific part of the map you can see
that the photographers were actually
taking these classic routes like route
66 across the the southwest and you can
actually tracked photographers as they
were driving down the country and its
really interesting because if we click
here for instance this is jack delano
and he's in arizona and we see all of
these photographs were taken in march of
1943 that all of these photographs are
longing this route 66 were taken in
march of 1943 so what this was doing was
adding new context in New ordering a new
metadata that we're still trying to
figure out how can we incorporate it
back into the original photographs
because the the photographs as they sit
on the Library of Congress is just these
are all in march of 1943 but really
because we know where they were taken
and we have that data and we know that
he's went east to west because we have
some notes and letters and you can see
that i think i think he starts in march
and ends in April we know which
direction he went we actually know some
latent information about the photographs
we know that well unless he was driving
insanely and kind of popping up and down
and back and forth which he probably
wasn't he's probably going in some
systematic order down the highway and so
we know something about the ordering of
these photographs and so if you're
writing about how did jack delano view
the US and you wanted to write a
research paper about him it might be
really helpful to see well how did he
what sorts of things that he start
taking photos of what sort of things
that he stopped taking photos I would
like at the end of his trip and how did
that change and without this
visualization you wouldn't I don't even
know that I would have thought about
that piece of it and I certainly
wouldn't have been able to do it without
physically you know getting out a map
and marker and plotting them all out
which gets to be a lot when you have
165,000 photographs so those are just as
some examples of how you can go into the
data from our
site and we're still as I said we're
still sort of testing it and playing
around but it's up there and we're
hoping people will go and break it and
give us feedback and so when it really
goes live but everything works kind of
Chris playing nicely on and we're
continuing to add other visualizations
on here as we play around with them